man this town is nuts Gotham we are
coming towards the end of season four
with that old corpse which is
incorrectly what I said the last episode
I reviewed was so I can only apologize
for that in any case so this is our
follow up from what was very clearly a
set up episode last time around and it's
just kind of a mixed bag I'll I mean
let's deal with the big thing right off
the bat which is Jeremiah effectively I
was gonna say effectively replacing
Jerome but definitely now our
perspective future Joker cuz Jerome's
dead he's definitely dead you know to
quote The Wizard of Oz really most
sincerely dead so he's not coming back
and now we've got Jeremiah and I the
thing is I don't think that the way in
which Jeremiah is being played is an
invalid way to play the character as I
understand him I don't think it's even
necessarily an invalid way to play the
Joker
the problem is there's no way to not
compare him to Jeremiah because it's the
same actor the characters are brothers
Jeremiah was a lot more fun the what I
appreciate in terms of shifting to
Jeremiah's The Joker versus Jerome is
Jerome was he was kind of cut in the
mold of the Heath Ledger Joker he was
into chaos that was kind of his deal so
he was a bit like Heath Ledger's Joker
doing an impression of Mark Hamill but
he was very high energy now what I
appreciate about Jeremiah is that
there's a great there's there's a
greater emphasis on his intelligence and
honestly that's something that I feel
like gets lost with the Joker a lot and
they just kind of leave
while he's unpredictable because he's
crazy but the the Joker at least in some
iterations is incredibly smart too so I
I'm interested in seeing that get
emphasized but at the same time this
guy's not high energy he's very quiet
he's very reserved and that's just I
can't help but think of all-star Batman
and Robin where Frank Miller wrote a
joker who never smiled and it's just
like well huh and it's it's so it's not
it's not working for me yeah we've got
two episodes left in the season so maybe
it'll turn around maybe it'll start to
work for me that's I usually happen to
me a lot with Gotham and Gotham
characters if I am to be completely fair
more often than not most of these
characters I didn't like when we first
encountered them and they grew on me
over time I think the list of characters
who I dug right off the bat is pretty
short it was fish and penguin that was
pretty much it everything else I took
some degree of issue with or wasn't
completely clicking on but you know at
this point I love almost all these
characters so you know I I gotta be fair
and give this guy a shot but first
impressions not great he was at his most
fun when he was impersonating Jerome
what's he gonna do so there's that we
continue to push the Lea ed thing which
is kind of working for me I love it but
I'm like you know what okay
I'm finding butch kind of interesting
now that he's more or less got his mind
back but he still got the Grundy
strength that's uh
that's interesting I really hope they
come up with something with with penguin
to do with these last few episodes I
mean I get just being opportunistic is
kind of his deal but I'm getting really
tired of watching him ascend to the top
getting knocked down ascend to the top
get knocked down dead did it did it did
it did it they got a I mean Ford seasons
in they gotta figure out where they want
him and keep him there
least for a decent stretch of time
because I'm getting tired of him
bouncing from the top and the bottom
over and over and over and over again
what else we got
Bruce is good in this he's he's another
one who's really grown on me I really
didn't like him first season but he he's
doing good work in this in this part at
this point whoa and I called it I called
him last time that that that lady
bodyguard was gonna be kind of our proto
Harley Quinn that does in fact appear to
be what's going down so hey go me I'm
probably not the only person who called
that um I'm not sure there's really all
that much else to say I don't have a lot
to go into on this one cuz it was
primarily a centerpiece on Jeremiah and
Jeremiah isn't working for me yet he may
get there I hope he does because
otherwise I'm just gonna be moaning the
loss of Jerome and I I would hate I
would hate the idea that we lost Jerome
just so the writers of this show can go
ha
the fans were wrong this wasn't the
Joker we told you it could have been
anybody like I cuz right now it feels
like they made the switch just so that
they can I don't know claim some kind of
victory cuz narrative Lee at least so
far it hasn't gained us anything I think
the best thing that Jeremiah did a
Cyberman person a Jerome was when he was
kind of mocking Jerome's plans as being
petty or small-minded or foolish again
emphasizing the intelligence so you know
maybe if they really leaned in heavy on
that it'll work better we'll see I guess
I got a couple more episodes they get a
surprise you want to wrap up though
because there's him and there is Ra's al
Ghul and I can't I can't remember
IV still had stuff she was trying to do
or they kind of wrapped up on her
I can't remember now new IV didn't leave
that big impression on me but I guess
that'll wrap this one up so Gotham that
old corpse what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe to support
me on patreon if you want to help try
and make the show better if it's
possible links for all this stuff and
more is down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]